g'day everyone my name's lucas and like
a wild koala spreading rampant chlamydia
throughout the australian bush so too
will i be spreading information to guide
you through the online digital jungle
surely you've encountered computer
viruses more than once most often cyber
criminals use them to make money
for example they might unbeknownst to
you turn your laptop or smartphone into
a digital zombie an element of a botnet
the infected device is engaged in
additional tasks for example mining
cryptocurrency sending spam messages or
even participating in attacks on other
websites
if the program is written correctly then
it can be very tricky to be noticed only
indirect signs show it increasing
traffic rapid battery discharge of the
processor overheating
and until you notice the problem the
attacker will be making money from your
device
but there is a fundamentally different
class of hacker programs they're not
about hiding but about aggressively
attacking
their task is to cause maximum damage to
your computer system
[Music]
so
hold on to your hard drives and keep
your nuclear code secret we're about to
jump into cyber warfare weapons of the
21st century combat viruses
[Music]
most of us associate the word chernobyl
with the disaster at the soviet nuclear
plant in ukraine it's now clear that the
soviet union has suffered one of the
worst disasters in the history of
nuclear power in 1986 a reactor
explosion and radioactive contamination
claimed hundreds of lives and made
thousands of kilometers of northern
ukraine uninhabitable now this tragedy
has become a turning point in the
development of nuclear energy around the
world
but experts in the field of computer
security
associated this word with a completely
different event
on april 26 1999 exactly 13 years after
the chernobyl explosion half a million
computers around the world were attacked
by a virus that was fundamentally
different from their predecessors
first it destroyed the user's files and
then it erased the program that manages
the computer's boot function
[Music]
it's called the bios
unlike documents or photos this program
is not located on the disk but in the
memory of the motherboard if you erase
the bios the computer simply will not
stop and it's impossible to restore the
program without special equipment
computer repair services couldn't cope
with the flow of customers many just had
to buy new computers
so the virus later called wind cih or
chernobyl
crossed the line between digital and
real world
this was the first time a program was
created to physically disable other
computers
experts promptly investigated the attack
and they found its author
fortunately the initials and references
to tartan university were left in the
virus code
through this we now know that chernobyl
was written by a 24 year old chinese
student chen ying-yao ironically the
reason for creating the program was the
self-confidence of the manufacturers of
antivirus programs
in advertising c they claimed that they
were able to withstand any threats
gen yin yo decided to prove this was not
the case
he couldn't begin to imagine how
vulnerable the computer world would be
i accept that challenge the virus got
into the web in the summer of 98
it didn't perform any suspicious actions
and so it went unnoticed by the creators
of antiviruses
the program was distributed along the
chain from computer to computer to
computer
and was waiting for april 26th to strike
all over the world
system administrators were in a panic
they had not yet encountered such a
threat before room is spread like
wildfire on the internet about programs
that spun up hard drives so fast they
would overheat
someone wrote that you could configure
the video card so that it would burn out
the monitor there was even an urban
legend about a computer virus that kills
people displaying a picture that would
cause seizures and epilepsy just like
that bad episode of pokemon did
[Music]
by the way contrary to another legend
the date of activation of the cih virus
is not related to the chernobyl disaster
chen finished creating the virus on
april 26 98 and he gave it exactly one
year to spread so it's just a
coincidence still the chinese student
did not expect such an effect
seeing the scale of the disaster he
actually joined and worked for the team
that wrote the antidote module
charges were brought against chen in
court but he didn't violate any concrete
laws at the time the end of the trial
left a lot of unanswered questions
in the meantime this didn't prevent chen
from working as a developer in large
electronic manufacturers
so if your computer has a motherboard or
video card with a gigabyte technology
logo
you know that this legendary agent of
chaos participated in its creation
now the us chinese and russian security
services were obviously interested in
this
they were starting to develop viruses of
their own for war in cyberspace it
sounds like a corny tech film from the
1990s but it's not this is real history
[Music]
in 2010
iran was close to creating its first
atomic bomb the processing plant in the
tans worked around the clock in huge
machines radioactive uranium was being
purified from excess impurities now this
is kind of similar to the work of the
spinning that goes on in a washing
machine
only it's not water that's being
squeezed out but the basis of a future
bomb
the plant employed 5 000 such
centrifuges the incident at natanz comes
a day after the iranian government on
saturday announced plans to launch over
150 new uranium centrifuges at the plant
suddenly
one of the machines was destroyed the
drum which at the time was spinning at a
speed of 50 000 revolutions per minute
broke away from its place and swept up
everything in its path
after a few minutes the same thing
happened with another drum
then another then another
engineers frantically were trying to
urgently stop the centrifuges but the
machines didn't respond to the computer
commands
explosions then were heard throughout
the premise and the complex was quickly
filled with uranium hexafluoride
when they finally de-energized the
complex more than 1 300 centrifuges had
already been destroyed
at the same time
similar accidents occurred at another
site the bashir nuclear power plant
which was being prepared for their first
launch
the equipment failed for unknown reasons
due to the destruction of important
nodes the launch of the station was
delayed until september next year
in general iran's whole nuclear program
had been set back several years of
course the secret police hunted for the
saboteurs but they did not find any and
this is not surprising after all the
cause of the problems was a malicious
program stuxnet and it was developed by
american and israeli programmers to
prevent iran obtaining nuclear weapons
stuxnet operated in three stages
first ineffective computers running
windows stuxnet is then distributed all
over the world at first it will be
discovered by programmers from belarus
and then on thousands of other computers
around the globe
but it didn't cause problems for
ordinary users its target was
exclusively for simmons hardware which
was being used at iran's nuclear
facilities of course such computers were
not connected to the internet therefore
phase two stuxnet invented the computers
of engineers engaged in setting up
equipment they often used usb flash
drives to install updates and through
one of these flash drives the virus
entered the network of the processing
plants
the program was tiny its size about half
a megabyte smaller than a digital photo
stuxnet didn't reveal itself with any
unnecessary actions the only thing it
did was look for an automated control
system or industrial equipment using
simmons installations
through it stuxnet reprogrammed the
centrifuges
the electric motors began to rotate at
such a speed that the entire body began
to vibrate the vibration weakened the
nuts of the fasting parts broke its
bearings and then the centrifuges jammed
and violently broke away
outwardly it looked like a breakdown
that was in no way related to the
operations of electronics or the control
program of the electronic motors
a detailed description of the work of
stuxnet is given in the report by
semantic expert liam o mercer
essentially yes what stuxnet is trying
to do is it's trying to
slow down or stop the enrichment of
uranium which can be used for atomic
bombs to say this report shocked the
world of computer security would be an
understatement we have well and truly
entered the era of military operations
being conducted in the digital world the
program has managed to do what israeli
aviation failed to do
slow down the nuclear program that
threatened both u.s and western
interests in the middle east
like any new weapon being developed the
publicity of stuxnet soon drew the
attention of criminals
and the possibilities such technology
would allow
already in march 2013 iran hit back a
group of izadin al-qasam hackers
successfully attacked the computer
networks of american express j.p morgan
and bank of america previously criminals
used computers to obtain information
about their opponents
but now intelligence was replaced with
destruction
the main goal of these types of attacks
is to disable high-tech systems
and then the cyber extortionists also
entered the game
[Music]
perhaps you've experienced viruses that
encrypt your data and then demand money
for their recovery
[Music]
my advice to you if you are faced with
such a problem
do not sponsor intruders but ask for
help from professionals
and it's always better to back up all
important data in advance on a separate
disk or in a secure cloud service there
is little to gain in paying off these
black mailers as inevitably they'll
release your data anyway or ask for even
more payments
unfortunately not all companies use this
advice
so if you live on the east coast of the
us then this spring you could face the
consequences of a successful attack on
one of the largest u.s pipeline systems
i appreciate that you have joined us
today to provide answers to the
committee and the american people on how
a group of criminals was able to
infiltrate your networks steal nearly
100 gigabytes of data in just two hours
and then lock your systems with
ransomware to demand payment colonial
pipeline delivers fuel and petroleum
products from texas to new york new
jersey and 17 other states across 8 500
kilometers up to 30 million barrels a
day are pumped this is almost half the
fuel that the entire east coast consumes
and on may 7 2021 the colonial pipeline
computer system was attacked by a
well-organized group of hackers
unfortunately it's always easy to talk
about events like these if they happened
many years ago
when detailed results of investigations
expert reports and testimonies of the
events appear on the web we still know
relatively little about the attack on
the colonial pipeline what we do know
for sure is that the company's network
was attacked by the darkside hacker
group the attackers stole more than 100
gigabytes of critical information
contracts with customers suppliers
programs to ensure financial
transactions and the control and
monitoring of the pipeline itself most
of the files are copied at first and
then encrypted
the attack use the easily adaptable
software
ransom darkside is designed to work with
windows and linux they used reliable
encryption algorithms so it was
impossible to return the data without a
key
colonial pipeline lost control over its
own computers and service the billing
system of the colonial pipeline was
blocked the company couldn't issue
invoices or even keep records on the
shipped fuel
information security specialists assumed
that the equipment of the pipeline
itself was under attack and in order not
to repeat the scenario in iran the
leadership decided to stop the entire
system on may 9th u.s joe biden was
forced to declare a state of emergency
already by may 13 17 000 gas stations
were out of fuel some gas stations
reporting they have no gasoline to sell
retail gasoline prices were through the
roof a 10-year high and airlines were
forced to change their flight schedules
they just didn't have enough fuel for
planes on the east coast the
extortionists demanded a ransom of 75
bitcoins and despite the first
statements to the press colonial
pipeline paid the necessary amounts
hackers fulfilled the terms of the deal
and gave the company's engineers back
their encryption keys with instructions
on how to restore their systems but the
story does not end there
during the investigation of the incident
fbi agents managed to establish that the
attack on the pipeline was far from the
first success of dark side in less than
a year 90 million dollars worth of
bitcoins were transferred to the group's
crypto wallets
about 100 companies in all were affected
by the hacker's activities
all of them
preferred to transfer the required
ransom without
unnecessary publicity let's say however
the management of the colonial pipeline
was a bit more clever it involved the
fbi experts during the transfer of their
bitcoins as a result they managed to
return more than 60 of the 75
transferred coins
we can say that the colonial pipeline
rode out the storm relatively easily but
i think even more high-profile crimes
are waiting for us ahead are we seeing a
rise in these types of attacks yes
particularly over the past year you
mentioned some figures that that to me i
think add up to this one that we know
well which is 2 400 school systems
governments and healthcare facilities in
2020 were reportedly the victims of
ransomware and that's only the reported
victims how not to become a victim of
these hackers
even if you give up your computers or
smartphones well unfortunately you will
not be able to completely protect
yourself you see our entire civilization
has long been hooked on computers
computers monitor power plants pipelines
they watch air traffic and traffic
control lights without computers it is
already impossible to imagine the work
of rescue services and military
operations
complex information systems have become
a soft underbelly for all mankind
therefore i strongly encourage you to
take a reasonable attitude to
cybersecurity issues my recommendations
are extremely simple
do not trust the statements of antivirus
manufacturers
absolutely reliable programs do not
exist in none of today's cases have they
managed to cope with these threats
therefore you should know that even if
your antivirus does not see a dangerous
program on your system
doesn't mean there are no such programs
perhaps they like chernobyl are still
waiting in the wings forget about usb
storage devices flash drives and
removable disks are one of the main
channels for transmitting malware
don't forget that just one flash drive
caused more damage to the iranian
program than all of the embargoes and
assassinations combined finally
carefully monitor the programs for
remote access and if possible completely
abandon them
according to one version darkseid
hackers penetrated the colonial pipeline
network for the first time
simply by using a compromised team
viewer password
joey
how are you
no no doing
how you doing
what how are you doing damn it carl
goodwin
and of course stay on the sum sub
channel there are many more still
interesting mysterious and truly
frightening stories ahead now where did
my koala get off to
[Music]
you